because demar was heated he wants a
review now this defense by demar derozan
excellent the bluff you get torrey craig
cut into the basket
that ball looks like it's off to mars
leg but he was emphatic about it yeah
and credit aisle to sumo you're right
adam
oh no that's uh i think that might be
off craigslist yeah maybe
there's a challenge opportunity the tip
to the rim would not go right on the
deck to save it
one point game final seconds
bulls look for the win
derozan
to win it
[Applause]
to more derozan delivers
[Applause]
the play is under review to see if the
basket is good prior to the expiration
of time
a herculean shot
from demar derozan
[Applause]
what a shot by demar derozan they will
look to see if it stands ruling is
confirmed
and demar derozan comes right to the
headset
[Applause]
debo
this was a tough one tonight
pacers pushed you it was a little bit of
a frustrating night at times for you
walk me through the final play that wins
it
man uh
trying to get a stop they've been
killing us on the boards
we got a much needed stop kobe doe for
the ball
i just got the ball and just wanted to
size it up
either win and go home you know
i knew they was going to switch i just
want to get a good look at the rim by
the time i looked up i didn't realize
the clock was so low and i had to get it
off
give me a sense of you
in those moments everybody has spoken
about your poise in the fourth quarter
in particular but in the final seconds
of the game do you clear out is your
head clear just give me a sense of you
yeah you got to clear up going into the
fourth long is the game close you got to
keep a level head
stay balanced and you know
enjoy the moment you know it was one of
those tough games
nothing was going right for us we stuck
with it got to give credit to my
teammates
we kept fighting we kept fighting put
out the win demar derozan a phenomenal
fourth quarter shot to win it six in a
row for the bulls congratulations
an absolutely
clutch incredible shot to put the bulls
13 games over 500 for the first time
since 2015. you know it might not go
down in the box score is his greatest
game but down the stretch demar derozan
made every play it was the help defense
now there's point seven on the shot
clock because they get that ball knocked
out off him he makes the play at the rim
to deflect the lob and then end of the
game
i mean this is just absurd off one foot
fading away gets caught with the clock
demar derozan mr fourth quarter what a
performance and what a win for the bulls
six in a row for the first time in four
years 13 over for the first time in
nearly seven what a game what a win for
robbie